[Music]
in 2021 some dared to imagine a
post-covered world
while others had those dreams shattered
in 2022 tide of instability and
uncertainty
people will seek out firm assurances
so what's really on the horizon
from exploring the universe and the
metaverse
to seismic power shifts and new fashion
trends
here are five stories that will shape
the world ahead
in 2022 china will test america's global
leadership
around november the communist party will
hold its 20th congress
where it will surprise no one when
president xi jinping seeks another term
as china's top leader
not since mao zu dong has a ruler
amassed so much power
but while mao's china was closed off
from the world
xi's ambitions are far-reaching
part of that idea of this kind of
uniquely impressive and powerful chinese
leader is that he is going to be a rival
center of gravity to an america that the
communist party at least is sure is on
its way out
in november on the other side of the
pacific americans will hold their
midterm elections
polls suggest president biden's
democrats could lose their slim majority
in both the house and senate
leaving a dysfunctional divided
government and a poor advert for
democracy
if you were a member of the communist
party in china and you look at images
from the west particularly america and
you see chaos you see protests you see
violence you see racial divisions
democracy in the american sense is a
wicked lie that it pretends to be a
system that delivers for ordinary people
but it can't even achieve the most basic
achievement of keeping people safe and
alive in a pandemic
for the chinese communist party the
western system led by america is in
terminal decline the only country in the
world powerful enough to stop china's
rights and 2022 is going to be a study
in contrasts as seen from beijing other
countries are speeding up and america's
falling behind the world has taken
notice by the way
including our adversaries
while americans fight to shore up their
democracy president xi will use the year
to try and showcase how china's
autocracy is more effective and so more
legitimate
whitewashing the fact that far away from
the glittering skyscrapers much of china
is poor polluted and unequal
the chinese communist party would like
to be loved it will settle for being
respected they want the world to look at
china's rise china's handing of coved
they hope successful hosting of the
winter olympics in february 2022 the
strength of china's economy and to think
you know what all of our qualms about
chinese human rights china's autocratic
iron fisted system of
government maybe those don't matter
as much as china's success
by the end of the year after president
xi steps onto the stage in the great
hall of the people to cement his power
china will look more ready than ever for
a post-american age
the core message of china under xi
jinping in 2022 it's a brutal one that
china's version is winning and that the
west is losing
[Applause]
the dream of flexible remote working
will collide with reality in 2022
as many of us head back to the office
but not five days a week and not nine to
five
hybrid working will become the new
normal
a hybrid model is really some sort of
mix it tends to be a mix of working in
the office and working from home
working parents and people with long
expensive commutes are among those who
stand to benefit from flexible working
if done well
a hybrid office could improve
inequality the gender pay gap all sorts
of things but 2022 will see debate over
what that hybrid model should be
a survey in america showed that the
average employee would like to work from
home for around half the week
but their bosses want them to spend
close to four days in the office with
just one day working from home
both employers as well as employees will
need to find a sort of middleweight
between the benefits that became really
clear
during the pandemic of remote works but
also the benefits of the offers that
were missed brainstorming something
that's often mentioned the creative
process was often missed networking
hybrid models could offer the best of
both worlds but only if the pitfalls can
be avoided
one of the greatest risks from the
hybrid model is probably that it means
different things to different people
surveys show that 85 percent of women
currently working remotely want
flexibility
compared to 79 of men
and people of color want more time
working from home than white people
a survey by future forum showed that
only three percent of black knowledge
workers in america want to return to the
office full time compared to 21 of their
white counterparts
fitting into a predominantly white
office in dealing with subtle bias and
racism are among the factors that are
likely to make remote working more
appealing
it's not a problem that different groups
have different preferences or that some
might want to come to the office more
than others but it is a problem
if being in the office more gets
rewarded
[Music]
presenteeism bias is a well-known
phenomenon that as a manager you're not
doing this on purpose but you tend to
think that the people who you see
regularly on the office floor
automatically as more dedicated and more
productive than those who you don't see
the problem is if women and minorities
prefer to work from home
bosses will see mostly white men in the
office
[Music]
some people talk of the the office
becoming a man cave so the place where
younger men all go and women will be
seen much less if you take it to its
extreme you could imagine the office
becoming yeah a little bit more like it
was in the in the 50s right and which is
not exactly progress
2022 is the year the dust settles and
new ways of working are figured out
but if not thought through there's a
risk that hybrid models will undo
hard-won gains in equality and diversity
[Music]
[Music]
the metaverse is the next frontier
in 2022 you'll be hearing a lot more
about the metaverse
so what is it
and what will it be used for
from microsoft's point of view what is a
metaverse it's an internet that you can
actually interact with like we do in the
physical world
metaverse is an umbrella term that
refers to online virtual worlds and the
idea of linking them together
and just as the internet was able to do
new things because we connected all of
the computers and the networks together
the idea is that if you link together
these virtual worlds that opens up all
sorts of exciting new possibilities
worlds where people hang out are nothing
new
in 2003 the online game second life
allowed people to enter a virtual space
as avatars and interact with each other
[Music]
but today's virtual worlds
are much more realistic
the online game fortnite blurs the line
between social space and video game
whether you put on a vr headset to go
into these worlds or you just use a
normal screen like on a smartphone or a
pc is up to you i know it looks a bit
silly wearing one of these things that's
kind of not the point it doesn't really
you look a bit stupid wearing a scuba
mask but you know you do it because it
allows you to do a fun thing
tens of millions of people already play
games and socialize in 3d worlds
[Music]
in 2021 over a million fans watched
ariana grande's concerts inside the
video game fortnite
but the metaverse is not just for gamers
during the covert 19 pandemic we've all
got used to interacting online
virtual meetings are here to stay and
the metaverse can make them more
lifelike
i think there's definitely an appetite
out there for more sophisticated forms
of online collaboration than just being
in a grid of boxes and a video call and
one of the ways that you could do that
would be to be in one of these virtual
environments with your co-workers or
your friends or whatever
both microsoft and facebook have already
built virtual workspaces such as this
one from facebook's horizon workrooms
where co-workers can come together
regardless of physical distance
now i love this sort of thing because
i'm a gamer and let me tell you it's
much more fun than going to meetings and
zoom
so i think this is where i get to shoot
lots of zombies
epic games maker of fortnite plans to
spend one billion dollars to develop its
vision of the metaverse
facebook has even renamed itself meta
our company is now
meta
it's already invested over 10 billion
dollars to make the metaverse a reality
some people say well this is facebook
just trying to change the subject
because it's got all of these other
problems but just because facebook wants
to change the subject doesn't mean that
there isn't something interesting
happening here
once a niche concept
2022 will see the metaverse reach a far
wider audience that doesn't mean that
everyone's going to be using it tomorrow
but it does mean i think that it's
something that we're going to be hearing
more about and that more people are
going to be getting involved
2022 will see african fashion enter the
global mainstream
we are home
there'll be a buzz in november when
marvel studios releases the sequel to
black panzer
the oscar-winning movie of 2018 was
famed for its african-inspired costumes
when the first black panther film came
out it got lots of people very
interested in african fashion
and we saw a massive shift in what
people were looking to buy and how
people were looking to embrace african
fashion
but the release of the sequel is just
one of the factors that will thrust
african designers into the limelight
sustainability will remain at the top of
the agenda in 2022 and brands like aaks
based in ghana are already ahead of the
curve
i work with artisanal women living in
the northern region of ghana to hand
make my bags
sustainability it's part and parcel of
my brand
growing up in ghana this is something
that we've always done
because it's all natural
from
the raffia that we are sourcing from our
farmers to the dyes that we are using to
making of our products by hand
i think african fashion really fits that
niche of being sustainable being
ethically made and people being able to
trace exactly where the things they're
wearing are coming from
in addition the black lives matter
movement has led to a demand for
products from black designers
fashion hubs in lagos nairobi and
johannesburg are already well
established but new designers stand to
benefit
too for aaks in ghana direct sales grew
700
in 2020 alone
i realized yes people wanted to show
support to black owned businesses people
wanted to purchase products from new
companies that they've never even heard
of and most importantly black owned
businesses
designers across the continent are also
poised to benefit from a surge in
e-commerce following the covid 19
pandemic
this is really transformational in terms
of for african designers who can now
have a place to showcase their work and
also have a place for people to buy it
[Music]
with lots of factors coming together in
2022 african designers are set to make a
lasting impact on the world
[Music]
uh the eagle has landed 2022 will see
the space race heating up again fueled
by old fashioned geopolitics
and new rivalries between space fanatic
billionaires
space has always been an arena for
competition we talk about the space race
ever since the launch of sputnik in 1957
and in 2022 we're going to see various
kinds of rivalries between various
groups playing out in space
by the end of the year china will
complete its tiangong space station
the international space station from
which china was excluded is due for
retirement after 2024
and china is keen to demonstrate that it
can build its own
but china and america are not the only
countries competing to show their
prowess in space
towards the end of the year india will
attempt to land a robotic rover on the
moon
they've tried this before and it didn't
work so they're going to have another go
and again india thinks that being able
to send things to the moon is a sign
that you know you're a serious global
power
the billionaire space race will pick up
speed throughout the year with richard
branson jeff bezos and elon musk
competing to become masters of space
tourism
2022 is shaping up to be the first year
where more people go to space as paying
passengers than as government astronauts
and this is made possible by the rivalry
between three space tourism companies in
particular virgin galactic blue origin
and spacex and all of them sent people
into space in 2021 and all of them want
to send more tourists into space in 2022
[Music]
even hollywood is getting in on the
action
with plans to shoot a movie in orbit
featuring tom cruise but it doesn't seem
to have got off the launch pad yet
meanwhile the russians already have
theirs in the can
actor yulia peresild and film director
klim shipenko returned to earth safely
after shooting scenes in orbit for a
film that will be released in 2022
so this is another example of a rivalry
between america and russia and in this
case as with sputnik the russians have
got there first
half a century after the moon landings
the space race is back and 2022 will see
the top contenders jostle for pole
position
i'm tom standage deputy editor of the
economist and editor of the world ahead
you can read more of our future gazing
coverage by clicking the link thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
you